[Music]
on this tuesday night ontario's new
order
and second state of emergency everyone
must stay home to save lives what the
new measures mean how they'll be
enforced and projections ontario has
reached
a dangerous point the prime minister
shakes up his cabinet
and reignites talk of a spring election
more
defiance and denial from president trump
people thought that
what i said was totally appropriate
warnings of more
mob violence as some senior republicans
turn their backs on him
plus low case counts and a high price to
businesses
sales would would definitely be down by
at least
half the two sides of nova scotia's
pandemic success
story
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after days of watching the covet case
count rise canada's largest province has
now declared a state of emergency
and issued a stay-at-home order it will
be enforced by the police but it is not
a curfew
new projections from the ontario public
health department today show the virus
is spreading faster than ever
and premier doug ford warns there will
be dark days ahead
we're at levels we've never seen before
cases and deaths
are at the highest level since the start
of the pandemic
here's what's projected ontario's
caseload is growing around three to five
percent every day if it reaches
seven percent the province could have
forty thousand positive cases a day by
mid february
with seven percent growth there could be
up to three thousand covid patients in
hospital icus
by mid-february that would be
overwhelming
doctors would have to decide who they
try to save and who they don't have the
time
or resources to treat those grim
projections would be made worse if the
new much more contagious
uk variant of covid 19 is spreading here
14 cases have been confirmed in ontario
if it is spreading further case numbers
could skyrocket
projections show they could double every
10 days
by march it's important for people to
know this is real
those graphs those are people they're
not just numbers
those are people those are your parents
your grandparents
your siblings your children and we all
need to take this very seriously
vaccines are coming but they aren't
rolling out fast enough to protect
against this
it will be months before the majority of
canadians are vaccinated
in the meantime the virus keeps winning
if people keep getting together
abigail beeman has tonight's top story
about what lies ahead
hallways will be used to house makeshift
intensive care beds
field hospitals will hold patients
throughout the winter
first ontario painted the picture of how
dire things are
and where they're headed we'll have to
confront choices that no doctor ever
wants to make
choosing who gets ventilators and oxygen
a problem everyone
worried about throughout the pandemic
new modeling suggests could now become
reality as for the long-standing problem
of long-term care outbreaks
this is a look at how many more there
have been from the summer until now
effective immediately ontario was
declaring a state of emergency
then the premier announced the
restrictions he'd hinted at for days
a stay-at-home order leaving only four
essential trips with new restrictions on
retail
anyone who can work from home is asked
to do so
online school is extended in the hot
zones until at least february 10th
and while the province suggested getting
outside for exercise
is allowed even city leaders don't yet
know what's what
we do need more information from the
province about exactly
what what they're envisioning
restricting but doug ford is clear about
stepping up enforcement
provincial and local police by law
officers
workplace inspectors will enforce these
new measures
bad actors who are caught they will get
fined
penalties may include up to a year in
jail
still comes down to the main areas of
spread so that's long-term care
that's you know some of our essential
workers factory workers marginalized
communities and i
i'm not sure all this addresses that
intensive care doctor quajo caramantang
is one of many calling for the province
to provide
paid sick leave saying for lots of
essential workers no sick leave
protection
means they're not likely to get tested
often
these groups are have multi-generational
homes and and it's those patients that
end up
the older patients that end up in our
intensive care units i would have liked
to have heard
more support for people who can't
self-isolate when they are known to be
sick or infected
ontario also announced eight additional
cases of the uk
variant so far they've only been able to
link five of those cases
to people with known travel history
suggesting the possibility of community
spread
more troubling with a variant scientists
estimate is
56 percent more transmissible abigail
beeman global news
ottawa there's an update tonight on the
ontario couple who were the first in
canada to test positive for the new uk
variant global news has learned they're
now under active investigation
the province announced the cases late
last month at the time officials said it
wasn't clear how the couple became
infected
it later emerged they had been in
contact with a recent traveler from the
uk
health officials won't comment on the
case because it's under investigation
saskatchewan is extending its public
health restrictions until at least the
end of the month
the province says the rules brought in
over the holidays will remain in place
until january 29th
they include a ban on household
gatherings and a limit on people getting
together outside the province
also says it will start giving out all
available doses of the vaccines
rather than holding back the second shot
the federal government says it has
secured 20 million more doses of the
pfizer biontec vaccine
that doubles the number of doses canada
has locked in
canada has now committed to buying 40
million doses from pfizer biontech and
40 million from moderna that is enough
to vaccinate everyone in the country
the federal government says canadians
will start to see a dramatic
acceleration in vaccinations
this spring to federal politics now
prime minister justin trudeau shuffled
his cabinet this morning
and that sparked a new round of election
speculation
opinion polls are adding to that
speculation a new ipsos poll done for
global news
shows liberal support remains at 36
percent
up one point since last month the
conservatives dropped three points to 29
percent
support for the ndp green and block
quebecois is holding steady
so how much did today's cabinet shuffle
have to do with the liberals
setting up for a spring election our
chief political correspondent david
aiken
explains excellency may we proceed
like everything else these days the
cabinet shuffle took place on
zoom bravo on this first ever virtual
swearing-in ceremony the shuffle was
triggered by the departure of the
industry minister navdy baines
he's a mississauga ontario mp who
announced he will not
run again in the next election it's time
for me to focus
on the most important job i have in life
being a dad baines had been one of prime
minister justin trudeau's closest allies
and
he was the political lieutenant for the
liberals in the greater toronto area
his departure is being broadly
interpreted in parliament hills back
rooms
as a signal that the trudeau liberals
are ready to take canadians to the polls
this spring likely after the tabling of
the federal budget
trudeau though says that is not his
preference from the very beginning of
any minority parliament
every political party understands that
elections can happen
but as i've been consistently saying we
don't want an election
but when asked directly if he could
commit to
not call an election until all canadians
are vaccinated
trudeau did not do so my commitment
is to doing whatever is necessary to
support canadians through this pandemic
with baines out
his political protege omar algabra will
play a bigger role
quarterbacking liberal fortunes in the
gta algabra tuesday was
elevated into cabinet to become
transport minister
let me first say how grateful i am for
the prime minister
to have put his confidence in me and
appointed me to this
to this incredible role the former
transport minister mark garneau
moves into the foreign affairs job while
the incumbent there
francois philippe champagne takes the
job that baines had
as industry minister finally winnipeg mp
jim carr is back in cabinet he had
stepped aside to battle cancer but
his health has improved and so he's back
in as minister without portfolio now
his job a tough one a political one
helped the liberals win some seats in
alberta and saskatchewan
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thanks
the prime minister confirmed canada's
land border with the u.s will remain
closed to non-essential travel a
shutdown
has been extended for another 30 days
until at least february 21st
in a push to speed up the vaccination
process in the u.s the guidelines there
are changing
federal health agencies now say states
should give vaccines to everyone age 65
and older
as well as any adult with an underlying
health condition and the administration
will stop holding back the required
second doses of the pfizer and moderna
vaccines to get more shots into people's
arms
states are not required to follow these
guidelines just 36 percent of the doses
distributed have been used so far
an average of 636 000 americans received
a shot each day
over the past seven days president
donald trump accepts no responsibility
for inciting the siege of the u.s
capitol
today he called efforts to impeach him a
hoax and a witch-hunt that he says will
stir up more anger
trump visited a texas border town today
his first public event since a mob of
his supporters
stormed the capitol last week in
washington the acting u.s attorney
general for the district says
hundreds of criminal cases are underway
in what is an enormous investigation
the charges range from trespass to
sedition to murder
and as jackson proskow reports there are
warnings more violent events are being
planned
by white supremacists in the days ahead
in this fragile moment president donald
trump poured more fuel on the fire
i've never seen such anger as i see
right now
refusing to acknowledge the role his
words played in inciting the violent
siege of the u.s
capitol at the hands of his own
supporters and people thought that
what i said was totally appropriate
instead of contrition
trump suggested those who seek to remove
or impeach him will face consequences
the 25th amendment is of zero risk to me
but will come back to haunt joe biden
and the biden administration
as the expression goes be careful what
you wish for we're gonna walk down
to the capitol it was the president who
told his supporters to fight back
as he lied about a stolen election in
the moments before the capital was
stormed
you'll never take back our country with
weakness you have to show strength and
you have to be strong
nearly a week after the uprising federal
authorities gave their first update
announcing at least 170 active case
files
and more than 70 arrests with
potentially hundreds more to come
we're looking at significant felony
cases tied to
sedition and conspiracy
in the aftermath the fbi has warned of
the potential for more violence across
the country
lawmakers have been briefed on several
alleged plots to disrupt the
inauguration of joe biden
state capitals are under threat the time
of 25th amendment emergency
has arrived it has come to our doorstep
it has invaded
our chamber inside the fortified u.s
capitol
lawmakers called on the vice president
to invoke the 25th amendment
to strip trump of his power despite the
objections of republicans
congress needs to stop this this effort
to remove the president from office
just one week before he is set to leave
instead members who face the violence
head-on are set to impeach trump
exactly one week before he leaves office
making him the first president in
history to be impeached
twice jackson that impeachment vote is
tomorrow the new york times is reporting
tonight senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell
is happy the democrats are trying to
impeach trump
what does that signal and donna a
growing number of republicans are on
board with impeachment at well as well
it suggests that they are worried about
long-term damage to the party because in
this country
money talks and right now donors are
fleeing the republican party
specifically refusing to contribute to
any member who supported objecting to
the electoral college win
and at the same time those same members
face things like censure
potential expulsion and calls on them to
resign so donna mitch mcconnell is
worried about the big picture here
and right now it's not good for
republicans
lots to unfold tomorrow jackson prescott
in washington thanks
a bike ride critics say crossed the line
coming up why the british prime minister
is being criticized tonight
oh my god this was the scene in
tuscaloosa alabama after alabama won the
nation's football college championship
thousands of fans partying in the
streets ignoring warnings
about covid19 rates that are soaring few
of them wore face masks they were
hooting and hollering while inches apart
police say 14 arrests were made on 18
different charges
british prime minister boris johnson
didn't go that far but he is under
pressure tonight for skirting public
health rules
london is under lockdown the rules say
even outdoor exercise
should be limited and people should stay
in their local area
but boris johnson decided to take a ride
further afield
redmond shannon explains the pandemic
has forced british hospitals to
ration oxygen firefighters and police
are driving ambulances
and another 1200 cova deaths were
announced on tuesday
that's why this is the sort of brazen
rule breaking
that infuriates so many police have had
enough
we will have more officers out on
dedicated patrols
to take action against the small few who
are letting us all down
just as police announced their intention
to issue more fines
the prime minister himself is being
accused of bending the rules
on outdoor exercise stay local is the
vague rule for exercising but on sunday
boris johnson was seen cycling at
london's olympic park
that is 11 kilometers from his home on
downing street
which has a number of other large parks
closer by
it wasn't illegal but it's forced his
interior minister to tread a thin line
staying local is absolutely crucial
staying away from other people
which is clearly what the prime minister
um did when he was taking his daily
exercise
residents near olympic park were mostly
forgiving
yeah it doesn't bother me i'm a cyclist
ice cycle runner and yeah i've
just been in westminster cycling you
know if you cycle there and back 14
miles that's
that's really not a lot so i
i mean i think i would do the same but
the incident has revived
a familiar phrase it's one rule for him
and his and his buddies
and then it's you know another rule for
the rest of the people british police
say enforcing a radius from home
would be too difficult although some
other european countries
are doing so redland shannon global news
london
gang violence in bc ahead why a younger
generation is falling victim
to organized crime
a gang war in bc is becoming
increasingly violent in the last two
weeks five people have been killed the
youngest just 14 years old
as robin gill explains a new generation
of young people in bc are being
recruited
into organized crime tequel willis was
just 14 years old
it appears someone wanted him dead and
they didn't hold back
he was shot eight times his grieving
family insists he wasn't involved with
the wrong crowd
how could you take someone's life so
young so soon
and think that it's okay it's not right
but the police were tracking willis and
say his death was the result of a
targeted shooting
it's a sort of tit-for-tat and they're
trying to establish
established dominance in the drug trade
doug spencer spent 30 years with the
vancouver police department
fighting organized crime he believes a
younger generation of gangsters is being
recruited
and scoffs at how naive they are
especially those who use social media
to brag about the murders and it's
reckless because
you know they're posting pictures of
themselves on facebook and stuff
the guys that are trying to kill you may
not even know what you look like but
you've just given them a picture of
yourself
there had been a lull in bc's gang
violence between january and october
2020
there was a 24 drop in gang-related
homicides
but a 34 percent increase in attempted
murder
the province's anti-gang unit says the
violence is cyclical
but allegiances have changed and old
beasts are resurfacing
how many times do we have to stand here
and and say
that this is the result of this
lifestyle you will
end up dead or in jail spencer has moved
on to working with
teens who are tempted to enter the gang
lifestyle and has a warning
the patchworn leaders
they're not the guys pushing the drugs
and shooting people and getting shot at
they're collecting all the profits well
the little street soldier
is the one who's in the cross hairs of a
gun
that message was apparently too late for
takel willis
but his family has confidence in the
police the police will do their job
to find out who did it robin gill global
news burnaby bc
there's a new development in the dispute
between commercial and indigenous
fishers in nova scotia
rcmp have charged 23 people in the
suspected torching of a lobster pound
used by indigenous fishers
the october fire was part of a violent
response to first nations launching
their own lobster fisheries to earn a
moderate living
23 people face break and enter charges
eight were also charged with mischief
pride and persistence next how one
province is keeping the virus
at bay
there are some coveted success stories
in canada right now atlantic canada is
doing
better than much of the country three of
the four provinces there reported
just one or zero new cases today nova
scotia had
one new case and it's taking pride in
how it's faring
though as ross lord reports some
businesses are paying a high price for
it
as a nova scotian heather rankin takes
pride in the province's ability to
suppress covet 19.
we are on the side of course of public
health and we don't want to interfere
with anything that's going on there
even though nova scotia's success in
keeping public gatherings to a minimum
has delivered a gut punch to her halifax
weinberg
sales would would definitely be down by
at least
half if not more the upside
fewer covet cases means less strain on
hospitals
in a province already struggling to meet
the demands of an aging population
it was that fear of of the virus
exploding
through our population but over the past
five months
no one has died from covet 19 in nova
scotia
other than a brief blip in november
there are very few positive cases
day-to-day
hospitalizations are rare despite a
spike in cases in neighboring new
brunswick last week
nova scotia's count stayed down on some
days
as low as zero emergency department
nurse
cheryl burbidge says it's a huge relief
we're continuing on with the load that
we have always had but we haven't had to
bring colbit into the
to the mix really hardly at all with the
number of cases staying low
and vaccinations expanding business
owners wonder
when the economy can return to normal
allow them to
be open alongside of covet in a safe way
so that we don't have to keep
facing this opening up closing down
situation nova scotia authorities are
signaling there's no
let up they're adding new measures like
mandatory coveted testing for rotational
workers
so while i know it's hard to do even
though our numbers are low and stable
we have to continue our cautious
approach that might mean keeping covert
and complacency at bay
at their own expense ross lord global
news
halifax and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada
is this wintry scene in humboldt
saskatchewan there are beautiful spots
all over canada
please email us yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and hope to see you
here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
bye-bye